another team in the afc west that hopes
to be in the thick of things the
chargers
they reportedly have spoken to urban
meyer and that would come as a bit of a
surprise to jaguars fans who were
thinking that they're just in the
process of slowly landing the plane in
jacksonville the jaguars have
essentially shut down their search they
interviewed arthur smith the titans
offensive coordinator on sunday night
because they'd asked for permission to
interview him a week before right so you
go through with it it's a zoom call
maybe you pick something up you pick his
brain
you do it it's a courtesy and hey maybe
you need to have him on standby in the
event that that it falls through with
urban meyer but you know this is the
thing about flirting with a college
coach who's left a couple of jobs and
you kind of scratch your head and does
he really want to come to the nfl and
you know you better be damn sure that
this is what you want to do before you
sign on the dotted line and this process
of getting yourself to the point where
you're damn sure can take a while and
there's a certain point chris
where i would say if you have to think
about it that way exactly right mike
maybe you just shouldn't be exactly
right i mean if you got to think about
it that long you're exactly right then
maybe you're not because it's not a
it's not a dip your toe in the water
type of job it's just not that you know
it is a job for a real psycho and i mean
that in a very nice way a psycho who's
like whoa it's 5 a.m i can't wait to get
to the job and work and coach and do
everything and whoa it's 11 p.m and i'm
gonna go home and go sleep so i can wake
up at five a.m and do it all over again
that's what you have to be you have to
be a machine and now let alone deal with
all the scrutiny and crap you gotta deal
with with managing a football team
that's my big question with urban meyer
we've seen him get
you know worn out at two previous stops
and really he was the king of those
spots right i mean it was the king all
the power
god urban meyer blah blah blah red
carpet whatever you want so now he's
going to go to jacksonville where you
know you're not going to be the king
you'll be the king of that organization
to a degree but you're not the king of
the overall college world and all that
i understand the chargers flirting with
urban meyer mike i get it yeah la it's
urban meyer it's a big name but i don't
get it really you have a chance as the
chargers with a young team right now to
get a quarterback and really have
something with justin herbert where you
can go wait we have a chance to have a
quarterback head coach combo for the
next 10 or 12 years 15 years who knows
with this kind of quarterback it could
be that type of marriage
that's not gonna happen with urban meyer
and that you know then you're back at
square one so that's why i just don't
like that combination when you kind of
link some of those factors together
i i i'm going to be far more basic about
it i think it's an urban meyer leverage
play yeah i get more out of the jaguars
right and that's the other thing it may
not be urban meyer sitting around
wondering what do i do what do i do
should i do it should i not do it it may
be that urban meyers decided to do it
but because he doesn't have someone else
knocking on the door he needs another
source of leverage to get to that 12.
you know it was so weird last week when
i heard he's looking for 12 and i think
12 is reasonable and then someone
commissioned one of the reporters at nfl
media to say that that was not relevant
and false well tell us what he wants
then if you're going to crap on the
number that's out there don't just crap
on the number that's out there tell us
what he wants and why would why would
anyone be retreating from wanting as
much as possible other than to save face
when they don't get it that was the
message he ain't getting 12. well maybe
he's still trying to get 12 or whatever
he's trying to get he wants 12 he's not
going to get it but he wants to get as
close to it as he possibly can that was
my immediate reaction when i saw that
yesterday and and this is the time of
year folks to just have a little more of
a critical eye because there are plenty
of ambitious reporters out there who are
trying to always have scoop scoop scoop
scoop scoop scoop scoop it makes you
susceptible to getting used by people
who have an agenda
who for example want to create leverage
for urban meyer and want to scare the
jaguars by planning a story that may not
even be true that he's talked to the
jaguars chris yeah the chargers no no i
mean
mike i mean the first thing i thought of
when i saw that was you know leverage
play at that point you know i i don't
again i don't know urban myers made a
ton of money throughout his career we
know that but i think it goes back again
even to like
what you just posed as a question a few
minutes ago
you know if if
if 10 and a half million to 12 million
is what it takes to put you over the
edge then maybe you don't need to do it
that's what i would say i mean
that's where i'd go man that that one
and a half million a year is what's
really going to do it after you've
already got 10 and a half in your you
know in your pocket
i just i don't know i don't i don't get
that either so we'll see where this goes
i mean urban meyer is certainly the the
unicorn of this coaching candidates uh
that are out there and i i would think
it's jacksonville or bust in my eyes
that's kind of how i look at it and two
other reasons to think that one in
jacksonville he's in charge
with the chargers he isn't going to be
in charge no way he's got a gm there and
tom telesco and uh you're gonna have to
answer to other people with the chargers
you can run the show like you did at
ohio state in gainesville
in jacksonville the other thing too is
to the extent that he's worried about
the bottom line
florida no state income tax california
lots of it for his bracket 13
13
13 cents of every dollar that you make
if you live in california and i'm this
isn't an anti-california thing it's just
13 cents of every dollar that you make
if you live in california in the highest
bracket goes to the state
if you're choosing you know 0
13 that's a factor so i look
it's
the plane is still landing the question
is will the wheels
touch and will he put a pen on the paper
and start making that u and finish it
all the way through to the second r at
the back end of meyer we shall see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports